ces fleurs superbe sont celles des
plantes les plus communes qui soit
puisqu'elle appartiennent à une famille
qui à elle seule compte près de 10 mille
espèces on peut en trouver sur plus d'un
quart de la surface fertile de la terre
le vent assure leur pollinisation et
leurs besoins en eau est nettement moins
élevé que celui de la plupart des arbres
elles survivent à la chaleur comme au
gel ce sont les graminées les herbes
ces plantes résistantes repousse
inlassablement
même si elles se font brouter chaque
jour si elles survivent à ces mauvais
traitements
c'est que le point à partir duquel elle
pousse se trouve situé à leur base au
ras du sol et que cette croissance est
permanente
les graminées offre ainsi un banquet
continue elle à une énorme variété de
créatures les plus grandes au plus petit
dans la broussaille des tiges vivent non
seulement des créatures qui mangent les
herbes mais d'autres qui se nourrissent
de ces herbivores le lézard
ap de petits insectes et les menthes
dévore les sauterelles quant aux
araignées elle s'attaque indifféremment
à toutes ces petites créatures les
termites sont parmi les plus industrieux
de ces petits laboureur sur le terrain
herbeux les tropiques
il se développe en si grand nombre
qu'ils consomment plus d'herbe à eux
seuls que les antilopes les vaches et
les kangourous
c'est dans ces savane du brésil que la
concentration de termitière est la plus
considérable permettant aux grands
fourmilier ou tamanoir d'en tirer son
alimentation exclusive
il place son long nez à l'entrée du nid
dégaine une langue qui peut atteindre 60
cm de longueur et grâce au mucus
collants qui la recouvre il
ap les insectes accrochés aux parois du
tunnel qui mène à la termitière
trente secondes plus tard le tamanoir se
retire prudemment avant que n'arrive à
la rescousse les termites soldats dont
il craint les morsures
c'est un vagabond toujours en mouvement
logeant à la belle étoile protégée du
froid par son épaisse fourrure
d'autres chasseurs vite à la surface des
termitières des larves de coléoptères
qu'ici dissimule pour y attirer des
fourmis volantes et autres insectes
grâce à la lumière qu'elles émettent
parfois les termitières sont attaqués
dans leurs fondations même par le plus
grands mangeurs d'insectes qui soit le
tattoo géant à colosse de 60 kg
redoutable démolisseurs moins délicat
que le tamanoir dans la recherche de sa
nourriture ils n'hésitent pas à
bouleverser le sol pour atteindre le
coeur du nid dès que les remparts de
celui ci sont défoncés la colonie
devient extrêmement vulnérables cette
souris a une préférence marquée pour les
termites
rien d'étonnant ce qu'on la trouve
régulièrement dans le sillage du tattoo
les plus redoutables adversaires des
termites sont pourtant de bien plus
petite taille
ce sont les fourmis carnivores qui
dévastent régulièrement les colonies de
termites
les colonies sont défendus par les
termites soldats
ces guerriers ont des mâchoires
totalement conditionné au combat au
point qu'ils ne peuvent s'alimenter
eux-mêmes et doivent l'être par les
termites ouvriers les guerriers sont
divisés en différentes espèces qui
disposent d'armes spécifiques
certains disposent de petites pinces
d'autres de ciseaux à céret d'autres
encore sont armés d'un bec au travers
duquel il injecte un poison de lure
ce
d'autres fourmis cependant sont
végétariennes tout comme les termites
elles utilisent leur mâchoire pour
briser les brins d'herbe et en 6 et les
tiges l'herbe est constitué
essentiellement de cellulose une
substance difficile à digérer les
termites dispose pour ce faire d'une
bactérie intestinale
les fourmis parasol ou sow basse
utilisent elles une méthode originale
laborieusement elle traîne les morceaux
d'herbe sur des distances atteignant
parfois 100 m jusqu'à l'heure ni qui
peuvent posséder plusieurs centaines
d'entrées les tunnels d'accès mène sous
terre à labyrinthe de couloirs de 25 à
30 mètres de long board et parfois de
2000 chambres toutes reliées entre elles
intel repères peut abriter jusqu'à 20
millions de fourmis
les travailleuses qui transportent leurs
débris d'herbe à cinq mètres sous la
surface du sol elle cultive sur cette
herbe un champignon d'une espèce qui ne
pousse nulle part ailleurs que dans ceni
avec un soin particulier les fourmis
parasols nettoie chaque brin d'herbe
méticuleusement elle élimine les sports
d'autres champignons qui pourrait se
trouver là elles détruisent les
mauvaises herbes en quelque sorte la
pellicule cireuse qui recouvre la
feuille est enlevée puis les fragments
sont hachées en menus morceaux que les
jardinières rassemblant litière pour y
cultiver le champignon ce champignon
digère la cellulose et prospère c'est
alors de lui que les fourmis se
nourrissent car sa chair et digeste
les fourmis soignent leur jardin
alimentaires avec beaucoup d'attention
évacuant inlassablement les menus
déchets les fragments de champignons ou
de feuilles un comestibles
le jour se lève sur la savane
brésilienne le campo sa rade
il fait encore frais mais le soleil
levant va rapidement évaporée la rose et
du pâturage et en réveiller les
habitants news les oiseaux des savanes
non pas d'arbre sur lesquels poussaient
leurs champs certains se contentent de
tiges d'herbe
d'autres tels le gobemouche allons que
des limites leurs droits sur leurs
territoires en le survolant bien en vue
le quart yama comme son homologue
africain le secrétaire est un chasseur
de serpents et d'insectes il surveille
le paysage du sommet d'une termitière le
tapir à brouter toute la nuit au lever
du soleil il regagne l'humidité de la
forêt et l'ombre de ces arbres qu'il
préfère nettement à la chaleur de la
plaine
le cerf des savanes quant à lui a dormi
toute la nuit ils ne commencent a peut
être qu'à l'aube
il préfère voir ses ennemis en pleine
lumière avec l'apparition du jour et de
la chaleur les reptiles commencent à se
manifester
le lézard thé greeks in est l'un des
plus redoutables les oeufs constituant
son repas préféré aucun oiseau si
combative soit il n'est en mesure de
repousser atego affamés
face à de tels prédateurs le péril est
grand pour des oeufs simplement posés à
même le sol
mais comment les mettre en sûreté les
arbres sont rares dans ces savane par
contre il y a des termitières le
collapse d'auray est une sorte de piques
qui creusent c'est termitière aussi
efficacement que ses cousins percent les
troncs d'arbres
si le collapse abandonne son nid d
crécerelle viennent s'y loger le mal ici
à capturer un lézard
il appelle sa femelle qui est en train
de couver c'est eux afin qu elle partage
son repas
les chouettes fouisseuses établissent
leur nid dans des trous à même le sol
éventuellement elle utilise un repère
abandonné par un tattoo le mal guette
sur le sommet d'une termitière car ces
petits ils sont à peine éclos et voilà
les niches
le bulgare
la famille trouve son salut dans une
prudente retraite le ndu est un oiseau
coureur d'amérique du sud
très proche de l'autruche africaine il
bâtit son nid en plein à même le sol il
n'a peur de rien et est de taille à
affronter un tatoo ou à lézarder weeks
in mangeurs 2 c'est le mal qui construit
le nid et qui couve qui est un cube les
oeufs qu'il est polygame avec environ
une demi-douzaine de femelles qui
pondent dans le même nid l'éclosion des
oeufs est généralement simultanée et les
jeunes vont s'aider mutuellement à
sortir de leur coquille sous la garde
attentive du père
il y à d'autres savane dans le monde
les prairies tempéré d'amérique du nord
ou les steppes de ghazi chacune avec
leur flore et leur faune particulière
mais les plus vastes prairies se situent
en afrique la savane africaine s'étant
pratiquement sans discontinuer du sahara
aux grandes plaines giboyeuse de
l'afrique du sud en s'étalant tout au
long de l'afrique orientale durant les
huit derniers millions d'années
c'est plein ont beaucoup varié en
étendue aujourd'hui la savane africaine
et moins vaste que par le passé en même
temps que le paysage en même temps que
la flore la faune évoluer les animaux se
sont adaptées à la nature
on trouve dans ces savane africaine plus
d'herbivores que partout ailleurs dans
le monde
différentes longueurs de coûts
différentes formes de dentition
différents appétit une énorme variété de
créatures qui fait que toute plante
grandes ou petites trouve un animal pour
la beauté
cet immense variété de bétail sur pied a
évidemment amené la prolifération des
carnivores les lions chasse en gros les
genoux et les zèbres les lycaons ou
chiens sauvages font de même les
guépards traque des animaux à leur
taille
les gazelles
avant que l'herbe ne s'étende sur les
plaines les ancêtres des antilopes ont
dû vivre dans des contrées buissonneau 2
en effet beaucoup de ces animaux se
nourrissent à la fois d'herbe et de
buissons comme le font les impalas le
gnou lui se nourrit exclusivement
d'herbe
il est donc tributaire des chutes de
pluie qui les font pousser et qui sont
très inégales c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gnou se déplacent
constamment à la recherche de nouveaux
pâturages
durant la courte saison des amours le
mal se fixe cependant sur un petit
territoire
il annonce ses prétentions en caracolant
aux alentours le mâle s'ébroue ils
cherchent querelle à ses rivaux afin de
démontrer sa force aux femelles de
passage
le but de toutes ces démonstrations et
de retenir les femelles sur ce
territoire
à
les jeunes eux adoptent rapidement les
allures insouciante et fantasque de leur
père
à l'est de la savane africaine vit un
autre ruminants qui chaque année
entreprend une longue migration à la
recherche de pâturages
le cob à oreille blanche vis dans le sud
du soudan
les femelles donnent naissance à leurs
petits durant la saison des pluies
quand la pluie cesse de tomber et que la
plaine commence à sécher la horde entame
son exode vers le nord guidés par
l'herbe nouvel en avant sont dans ces
nouveaux pâturages
le troupeau est canalisée par deux
rivières qui se rapproche lentement
l'une de l'autre
jusqu'à se rejoindre au confluent les
cob n'ont plus d'autre choix que de
tenter la traversée et c'est là que les
attendent les tribus merlet
pour l'école maintenant plus question de
faire marche arrière
il faut traverser
jour après jour les clubs tentent de
relever le défi plusieurs semaines
seront nécessaires pour le passage de
tout le troupeau en migration un million
de cobb réussiront à traverser 5000
seront tués pour régaler les merlus et
leur permettre de faire des provisions
pour les mois à venir
en mettant la viande va sécher au soleil
en dépit de l'embuscade eux des tribus
merlet la plupart des clubs atteignent
donc les riches pâturages du nord ils y
trouvent la nourriture grâce à laquelle
ils passeront les mois difficiles de la
saison sèche
là également il s'accoupleront et
l'année prochaine les ordres reviendront
pour traverser la rivière est procuré
une fois de plus de la viande aux merlus
l'herbe elle aussi repoussera
inlassablement cette plante remarquable
peut survivre un broutage intense au feu
aux inondations la seule chose qui lui
est fatale c'est la sécheresse que
tombent moins de pluie et les feuilles
blanches iront les racines se dé
sécheron et ne pourront plus fixer le
sol le vent s'en emparera les réduire en
particules de plus en plus fine en sable
et la terre deviendra dr